[Musique]
parce que lire un livre à son enfant
descend plus jeune âge c'est l'éveillé à
la lecture développer son langage et
aussi construire une cohésion au sein de
la famille que l'opération première page
au coeur de ses valeurs offre un livre à
tous les enfants nés en 2022 c'est une
action culturelle pour l'enfant si bien
pour le parent et ça nous encourage à
partager davantage avec nos avec nos
bébés tout simplement vous voyez bien
comment les familles se mobilisent
comment les nous-mêmes nous sommes
heureux de voir les parents
venez à notre rencontre et c'est
l'occasion encore une fois de passer
d'agréable moment mais surtout encore
une fois de renforcer les valeurs
éducatives et culturelles au sein des
familles réunionnaises une édition
illustrée avec ce livre intitulé maman
c'est quoi le monde au camp une maman et
son enfant s'émerveille du monde qui les
entoure de la douceur et de la
bienveillance et surtout
transmettre dans ce monde qui n'est pas
facile tous les jours
un peu d'amour dans nos
dans nos liens oui voilà dans nos
rapports à l'autre quoi les familles
sont allées à la découverte de cette
nouvelle opération première page dans le
jardin de l'État une édition qui
remporte toujours autant de succès quand
on boit voilà cette manifestation on ne
peut être que renforcé dans cette
conviction que le livre ouvra la culture
ouvra la liberté ouvre au monde puisque
c'est le sujet de ce de cette édition
tout le monde à travers le livre avec
l'amour de ses parents
et je pense que le jeûne à ce moment-là
il aura envie de d'apprendre de
connaître de découvrir le monde chaque
jour pour cette douzième édition portée
par le Département partenariat avec
l'État et la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales 14000 familles réunionnaises
recevront ce livre à récupérer dans les
PMI et les bibliothèques de Lille
[Musique]